hello
this is matthew from simply learn and
today we're going to go through
part one of a two-part series on
interview questions that you are likely
to be asked
if you are interviewing for a job that
focuses on devops so there are
approximately seven sections that we
cover in devops we go from
general devops questions source code
management with tools such as git
continuous integration and here we'll
focus on jenkins continuous testing with
tools such as
selenium and then you also have the
operation side of devops which is your
configuration management with tools such
as
chef puppet and ansible containerization
with docker
and then continuous marching with tools
such as nagios so let's just get into
those general devops
questions so one of the questions that
you're going to be asked is how is
devops different
from agile and the reality is is that
devops
is a cultural way of being able to
deliver solutions
that's different from agile if we look
at the evolution
of delivery over the last five to ten
years we've gone from
waterfall based delivery to agile
delivery which is on sprint
to where we are with continuous
integration and continuous delivery
around devops the whole concept of
devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at
being able to do continuous releases
what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code
continuously to your production
environment that means the operations
team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created
has to be able to go to production very
quickly which means you need to be
testing your code continuously
and then that production environment
must also be able to be tested
continuously and any changes or any
errors that come up have to be
communicated
effectively and efficiently back to the
dev and op
team another area in which i see that
devops is different is really the
response that we have for how we engage
with
the customer so the customer is coming
to your website to your mobile app
to your chat bot or any digital solution
that you have and has an
expectation when you're going through
and actually doing
a devops paradigm the old model would be
that you would capture requirements from
the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there would be these
barriers between each of those as we
move
faster through from waterfall to agile
what we saw
is that with agile we're able to respond
much faster to
customer demands so instead of it being
weeks or months
sometimes in some cases years between
releases
of software what we saw it would was a
transition to weeks and months
for releases on software now we see with
devops is that
the release cycle has shrunk even
further
with the goal of continuously delighting
the customer
how further has that release cycle
shrunk to there are companies that have
gone from having releases of once a week
or once every two weeks or once a month
to now having multiple releases a day
indeed
some companies have up to 50 releases a
day
this isn't something to also bear in
mind is that each of those releases are
tested and verified against test records
so that you can guarantee that the code
that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases
of devops so effectively there are two
main phases of devops there's the
planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
jenkins
that allows you to integrate between
both environments
some of the core benefits that you may
have to devops
are going to be some technical benefits
and some business benefits so when
somebody asks you
what are the benefits of devops you can
reply
that from a technical point of view
you're able to use continuous software
delivery to constantly push
out code that has been tested and
verified against scripts that have been
written
and approved you can be able to push out
smaller chunks of code so that when you
have an
issue you're not having to go through
massive blocks of code or
massive projects you're going through
just very small micro
services or small sections of code and
you're able to detect
and correct problems faster on the
business side
the benefits are absolutely fantastic
from a customer that's coming to your
website and or to your mobile app
they're going to see
responses happening continuously so
that the customer is always aware that
you as a company are
listening to their demands and
responding appropriately
you're able to provide a more stable
environment and you're able to
scale that environment to the demands of
the number of customers
that are using your services so how you
approach
a project that needs to implement devops
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in so there are effectively
three stages when it comes to actually
working
in a dev ops the first stage is an
assessment stage and
think of this as the back of the napkin
ideation stage this is where you are
sitting with a business leader and
they're giving you
ideas of what they would like to see
from feedback that they've had from
their customers this is blue sky
opportunity this is thinking of big
ideas
that second stage and this often comes
as a fast follow to stage one is
actually
proving out that concept so developing a
proof of concept and a proof of concept
can actually be a multiple different
things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something
that is as complex as a mini version of
the final
application depending on the scope of
the work that you're delivering will
really depend on how complicated you
want the poc
to be but with that in mind whatever
choice you make
you have to be able to deliver enough in
the poc
so that when you present this to a
customer they're able to respond
to that creation that you've developed
and able to give you feedback to be able
to validate that you are going with the
right solution and able to provide the
right
product to your customers that third
stage
is where you get into your dev ops stage
and this
is just the exciting part this is where
the rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog
of features that are being requested for
the solution
in contrast to doing agile delivery
where you just continuously work through
a backlog
with devops what you're also looking at
is putting in analytics and
sensors to be able to validate that you
are being successful with the solution
that being delivered so that once you
actually
start delivering out code that customers
can interact with
you want to be able to see what are the
pieces of the solution that they are
using what do they like
what is complicated where are the
failure points and you want to
use that data and feed that back into
your continuous integration
and have that as a means to be able to
backfill
the demand of work that gets completed
in the bank log so what is the
difference between continuous delivery
and continuous deployment so continuous
delivery
is based on putting out code that can be
deployed
safely to production and ensures that
your businesses and functions
are running as you would expect them to
be
so it's going through and completing the
code that you'd actually see
continuous deployment in contrast is all
about
ensuring that you're automating the
deployment of a production environment
so you're able to go through and scale
up your
environment to meet the demands of both
the solution
and the customer this makes software
development and release processes
much more faster and more robust
so if we look here we can actually see
where
continuous integration and continuous
deployment
come hand in hand so when you actually
start out with the initial pushes of
your code that's where you're doing your
continuous integration
and your continuous delivery and then at
some point you want to get very
comfortable with deploying
the code that you're creating so it's
being pushed out
to your production environment one of
the things that's
great about working with the tools that
you use in a devops continuous
integration
and continuous delivery model is that
the
development tools that you use the
containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect
the production environment and what this
means is that when you actually come to
deploying solutions to production
there are no surprises because your
development team
have been working against that exact
same environment
all the way through so a question that
you'll also be asked is you know what is
the role of a configuration management
in devops and so the role of
configuration
management really has three distinct
areas and the first and this is really
obvious one and this is the one where
you probably already have significant
experiences is the ability to manage and
handle
large changes to multiple systems in
seconds rather than days hours or weeks
as that may have happened before the
second area is that you want to
also demonstrate the business reasons
for having configuration management and
the business reason here
is that it allows it and infrastructure
to standardize
on resource configurations and this has
a benefit in that you're able to do
more with fewer people so instead of
having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller
more highly skilled team that's able to
actually manage
an even larger operational environment
and
thirdly you want to be able to highlight
the ability to
scale so if you have configuration
management tools you're able to manage
a significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in
it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed
on cloud or private cloud and allow you
to do this
with high accuracy so
how does continuous monitoring help and
maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in
and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring
is that with being able to effectively
monitor
your entire network 24 7 for any
changes as they happen you're able to
identify and report those
thoughts or threats immediately and
respond
immediately for your entire network
instead of having to wait
as it happens sometimes for a customer
to email or call you and say
hey your website's down nobody wants
that that's an embarrassing thing
the other three areas that you want to
be able to highlight are the ability to
be able to ensure that the right
software and the right services
are running on the right resources
that's your number one takeaway that you
want to be able to give of continuous
monitoring the second is to be able to
monitor
the status of those servers continuously
this is not requiring
manually monitoring but having a agent
that's monitoring those servers
continuously
and then the third is that by scripting
out
and continuously monitoring your entire
environment you're creating a self-audit
trail that you can take back and
demonstrate the effectiveness
of the operations environment that you
are providing
so one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for devops is amazon's
web services aws
and they have really five distinct areas
that you can zero in on board services
so when the question comes up
what is the role of aws in devops you
want to really hold out your hand and
list of
five areas of focus using your thumb and
finger so you want to have
flexible services built for scale
automation
secure and a large partner ecosystem
and having those five areas will really
be able to help demonstrate
why you believe that aws and other cloud
providers but aws is certainly the
leader in this space are great
for being able to provide support for
the role of devops
so one of the things that we want to be
able to do effectively when we're
releasing any kind of solution is to be
able to measure that solution
and so kpis are very important so you
will be asked for
three important dev of kpis and so
three that really come to mind that are
very effective
the first one is mean time to failure
recovery and what this talks about is
what is the average time does it take to
recover
from a failure and if you have
experience doing this
then look at the experience you have and
use a specific example
where you are able to demonstrate that
mean time to failure recovery
the second is deployment frequency and
with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy
solutions and what actually happens when
you're actually doing those deployments
and what
does the impacts to your network look
like when you're doing those deployments
and then the third one is really tied to
that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so
how many times did you deploy to a
server and something happened where the
server itself
failed what we're looking for when
you're going through and being asked
for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're
pushing out your infrastructure and then
the second
is being able to validate that
self-auditing
ability and one word of caution is don't
go in there and say that you have a
hundred percent success
uh the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment
and use that as a story for how you're
able to successfully
get over and solve that degradation so
one of the terms that is very popular at
the moment is infrastructure as code and
so you're going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your devops environment and
infrastructure's code really refers to
the writing of
code to actually manage your environment
and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this
series but you'll see that xml or ruby
or yaml
are used as languages to describe the
configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be
read by the machines that are actually
setting up the physical hardware
versus a traditional model which is
having software and installing that
software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure
as a service and infrastructure as code
is fundamental
to the foundation to infrastructure as
service
and then finally allows you to be able
to
talk about how you can use scripted
languages such as yaml
to be able to create a consistent
experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into
the next section which is source code
management and we're going to focus
specifically on
git the reason being is that get is
really the most
popular source code management solution
right now there are other technologies
out there but
for the types of distributed
environments that we
have uh source code management with git
is probably the most effective
so the first question you'll be asked
when it comes to git is to talk about
the difference between centralized
and distributed version control and if
we
look at the way that the two are set
up older technologies such as older
versions of team foundation server
though
the current version does actually have
git in it but older versions
required a centralized server for you to
check in and check out
of code the developer in the centralized
system does not have all the files for
the application and if the centralized
server crashes
then you actually lose all of the
history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code
to a server however for you to be
effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code
for the solution directly onto your
local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire
solution running on your local machine
this allows you to be able to work
effectively offline
it really allows for scalability when it
comes
to building out your team so if you have
a team
that may be in europe you can actually
then scale that team
with people from asia from north america
or south america
very easily and not have to worry about
whether or not
they have the right code or the wrong
code and in addition to that
if the actual main server where you're
checking in your code
does crash it's not a big deal because
you actually have each person has a copy
of the code so as soon as the server
comes back
up you have to check back in and
everybody's running back
as if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands
you use for working with git so if you
were to be asked the question is what is
the git command that downloads any
repository from github to your computer
on the screen we have four options we
have git push git fork
get clone and get commit the answer in
this instance would be
git clone now if you want to be able to
push
code from your local system to a github
repository using git
then first of all you want to be able to
do is connect the local repository to a
remote repository
and in the example you may want to talk
about using the command get remote add
origin and then
the actual path to a github repository
you could if you want to actually at
this point also talk about
other repositories such as git lab that
you can also work with or a private
git repository that would be used just
for the development team once you've
actually then
added the local repository into your
local computer then the second action
you want to use is a
push which is to actually push your
local files out
to the master environment so you use the
command git
push origin master so one question you
may be asked is what is the difference
between
a bare repository and a standard way of
initializing a get repository so
let's look through what is the standard
way so the standard way using git
init allows you to create a working
directory using the command git in it
and then the folder that creates is the
folder that creates all the revision
history
related to the work that you're doing in
contrast
using the bear way you have a different
commands for setting that up so
it would be git init dash dash bear and
it does not contain
any working or checked out source files
locally on your machine
in addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git
in it initialization so which of the
following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file
so we have git rm git mv get rm-r
or none of the above well in this
instance it would be
gate mv a question that you'll be asked
around
commit is going to be what is the
process to
revert a commit that has already been
pushed and made
public and there are two ways you can
address this the first
is to actually address the bad file in
the new commit and you can use
the command git commit dash m and then
put in
a comment for why that file is being
removed the second
is to actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad
commit and then to do that you would use
git
revert and then the commit id and the
commit id
and it could be something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that
from the the commit that you had made
but that would allow you to
revert any bad files that you had
submitted
so the two ways of being able to get
files from a get repository and you're
going to be asked to explain the
difference between
git fetch and get paul so get fetch
allows you to
fetch and download only new data from a
new repository
it does not integrate any of the new
data into your working files
and it can be undone anytime if you
wanted to
break out the remote tracking branches
in contrast get pull updates the current
head branch with the latest changes from
the remote server so
you get all of the files and downloaded
it downloads new data and integrates it
with the current working files you have
on your system and it tries to merge
remote changes with your local ones
so one of the questions you'll get asked
about get is what is a get stash so
as a developer you will be working on
the current
branch within a solution but what
happens if you come up with an idea
where
it's something that will take a
different amount of time
for you to be able to complete but you
don't want to interrupt
the mainline branch so what you can
actually do is you can actually create a
branch
that allows you to start working on your
own
work outside of the mainline branch
and this is called get stash allows you
to be able to
modify your files without interrupting
the mainline branch
so you once you start talking about
branching and get be prepared to
answer and explain the concept of
branching
so essentially what it allows you to do
is
have a mainline master branch that
has all the code that the team is
checking in and checking out
against but allows you to have an
indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built
in parallel to the mainline branch and
then at some point
be reintroduced to the mainline branch
to allow the team to add in
new features and so if we look through
the merge and get rebase
these are the two features that you'd be
using continuously
to be able to talk about how you take a
branch and merge it back into
the mainline branch so on the left hand
side
we have git merge which allows you to
take the code that you're creating and
merge it back into
the master on the right hand side what
you have is a slightly different
approach
this is for projects where you reach a
point in a project where you go okay
we're going to effectively restart the
project
at this point in time and we want to
ignore the complete history that's
happened before that
and that's called get rebase and that
would allow you to
rewrite the project history by creating
a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it
you can if you want to very quickly and
easily find out
all the files that have been used to
make a particular commit so when
somebody asks you the question
how do you find a list of files has been
changed in a particular
commit you can actually say that all you
have to go is find
the command get diff dash tree dash
r and then the hash that you would use
for the commit and that would actually
then give you a breakdown
of all the files that have been made
with that particular commit a question
you'll be asked when you're talking
about merging files
is what is a merge conflict in git and
how can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have
two or more branches that are competing
with commits
in git and you have to be able to
determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in
and to actually help resolve this issue
you'd actually go in and manually edit
the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final
merge so let me go through the steps
that you would take
to be able to illustrate this when
you're talking about this particular
question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be
under the repository name you want to
select a pull request
and you want to be able to show how that
pull request would be
demonstrated inside of github
so within the pull request there's going
to be a highlight
of conflict markers and you'll be able
to select which conflicts
you want to keep and which you want to
merge and which ones you want to change
so it's a step through how you would
actually resolve a merge conflict
and the first step would be under github
you want to be able to pull the
repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve they'll pull up a file that
will list out
all of the conflicts for you near the
bottom of that file
will be a list of the requests that need
to be resolved
and then if you need to make a decision
on which branches you want to keep or
which ones you want to change that will
have to be something you have to
put in instructions inside of the file
you'll actually see that there are
conflict markers within the instructions
which are going to ask you which files
you want to change
which ones you want to keep if you have
more than one merge conflict in your
file scroll down to the next set of
conflict markers and repeat steps
four and five until you resolve all of
the
conflicts you will want to mark your
file as
resolved in github so that the
repository knows that you are having
everything resolved
if you have more than one file with a
conflict then you want to go then onto
the next
file and start working on those files
and just keep repeating the steps we've
done up to this point
until you have all of the conflicts
resolved and then once you have
all of the resolutions created then you
want to select the button which is
commit
merge and then merge all your files back
into
github and this will take care and
manage the
resolution of the merge conflict within
github so you can also
do this through command line and with
the command line you want to use
get bash and so you want to as a first
step
open up get bash and then navigate to
the local get repository
and command line by using the cd change
directory
and then list out the actual folder
where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected
with the merge conflict and in this
instance here you can actually see
the file styleguy.md has a merge
conflict in it and as before with
working with
github you actually go through and use a
text address and use any text editor but
as you go through and edit out
what you want to keep and what you want
to uh manage in your conflict so you
actually have
a resolution that's been created so that
you'll be able to then once you're using
the conflict markers you can actually
merge your files together so that the
solution itself
will allow you to incorporate your
commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and
applied your changes you're able to then
merge the conflicted commits
into a single commit and able to push
that up to
your remote repository all right let's
talk about the next section which is
continuous integration with
jenkins so the first question you'll be
asked about with jenkins is
explain a master slave architecture of
jenkins so the way that jenkins is set
up is that the jenkins master will pull
code from your remote git repository
such as github
and will check that repository every
time there is a code commit it will
distribute the workload of
that code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code
to all of the jenkins slaves and then on
request the jenkins master and the
slaves will then carry
out all the builds and tests to be able
to produce
test reports the next question you'll be
asked is
what is a jenkins file and simply put a
jenkins file is a text file that has a
definition
of the jenkins pipeline and is checked
into a source code
repository and this really allows for
three distinct
things to happen one it allows for a
code review and iteration of the
pipeline
it permits an audit trail for that
pipeline and
also provides a single source of truth
for the pipeline which can be
viewed and edited so which of the
following commands
runs jenkins from the command line is it
java
jar jenkins dot war java dash war
jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins jar
java dash war jenkins.war
and the answer is a java dash jar
jenkins.war so when working with jenkins
you're going to be asked
what are the key concepts and aspects
of working with the jenkins pipeline and
you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through four
key areas and that is pipeline node
step and stay so pipeline refers to the
user-defined model of a cd continuous
delivery pipeline
node are the machines which is which are
part of that jenkins environment
within the pipeline step is a single
task that tells jenkins what to do at
that particular point in time
and then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct
subset of tasks performed through the
entire pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to define dependency
in maven and do we have a build.xml
b palm.xml c dependency.xml or d
version.xml and the answer is palm.xml
working with jenkins you're going to be
asked to explain the two types of
pipeline
used in jenkins along with the syntax
and so
a scripted pipeline is based on
groovyscript as their domain specific
language for jenkins and there are one
or more
noteblocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline
on the left hand side you can actually
see what the actual script would look
like and the right hand side
shows what the actual declaration for
each
section of that script would be the
second type of jenkins pipeline
is a declarative pipeline and a
declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define
what the pipeline should look like and
then you can actually at this point
use an example to actually break out how
blocks are used to define the work
completed in a decorative pipeline so
how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up
jenkins to your jenkins home directory
and then create a copy of that directory
it's really as simple as that the
question you'll be asked as well
is how can you copy jenkins from one
server to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can
move a job from one installation of
jenkins to another by copying
the corresponding job directory the
second would be to create a copy of an
existing job directory and making a
clone of that job directory
but with a different name and the third
is to rename an existing job
by renaming a directory so security is
fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the
center core to all the work that gets
completed
within a devops environment there are
three ways in which you can
apply security to authenticate users
effectively and when you're asked about
this question
of security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database
that uses secured user data from end
user credentials
b is you can use a ldap or lightweight
directory access protocol server
to be able to authenticate jenkins users
or c you can actually configure jenkins
to authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more
modern method of being able to
authenticate users
you're going to be asked how to deploy a
custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially
the four steps you want to go through
are
first of all copying the dot hpi plugin
file into the jenkins home plugins
subdirectory you want to remove the
plugins development directory if there
is one
you want to create an empty file called
plugin.hpi.pinned
and once you've completed these three
steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available
how can you temporarily turn off jenkins
security if the administrative user
has locked themselves out of the admin
console this doesn't happen very often
but when it does it's good to know how
you can actually get into jenkins and be
able to resolve the problems
of authenticating effectively into the
system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file
you should see that it's set to true
which allows for security to be enabled
if you then change the user security
setting
to false security will disabled allow
you to make your administrative changes
and will not be re-enabled until the
next time
jenkins is restarted so what are the
ways in which
a build can be scheduled and run in
jenkins well there are four ways in
which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is
when source code management commits new
code into the repository you can
run jenkins at that point the second can
be the
after the completion of other builds so
maybe you have multiple builds in your
project that are dependent to each other
and when
so many other builds have been executed
then you can have jenkins run
you can schedule build to run at a
specified time
so you may have nightly builds of your
code
that illustrates the changes in the
solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build
a environment on request occasionally
you will want to also restart jenkins
and so it's good that when a question
around how do you restart jenkins
manually comes up that you have
the answers and there are two ways in
which you can do it one is you can
force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the
jenkins url that you have for your
environment slash restart
or you can allow all running builds to
complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of
the url for your jenkins environment
safe restart
so let's go into the fourth and final
section of this
first video which talks about continuous
testing
with selenium so the first question you
will be
asked most likely around selenium are
what are the four
different selenium components and again
you will want to hold open your fingers
because there are four distinct
environments you have selenium
integrated development environment or
selenium ide you have selenium remote
control
or selenium rc you have selenium web
driver and then selenium grid
you'll be asked to explain each of those
areas in more detail but let's
start off with by looking at selenium
driver what are the different exceptions
in selenium webdriver so it's useful to
remember
that an exception is an event that
occurs during the execution of a program
that disrupts the normal flow
of that program's instructions and so we
have four
we have a timeout exception an element
not visible
exception no such element exception and
a session
not found exception and each of those if
we step through them
are the four different types of
exceptions that can be thrown up when
using
the selenium web driver so as we evolve
in our digital world with the different
types of products that are available for
us to be able to
build solutions onto multiple platforms
you're going to be asked
can selenium and other devops tools run
in other environments and so a good
question around this is cancelling them
test an
application in an android web browser
and the short answer is
absolutely yes it can we have to use the
android driver for it to be able to work
so you want to be able to talk about the
three
different types of supported tests
within selenium so when the question
comes up what are the different test
types supported by salaam
you can answer that and there are three
different types of tests
first is a functional test second is a
regression test
and third is a load testing test the
functional test
is a kind of black box testing in which
test cases are based on
a specific area of feature within the
software a regression test
helps you find any specific areas that
functional tests or non-functional areas
of the code wouldn't be able to detect
the load testing test allows you to
monitor the response
of a solution as you increase the volume
of hits in how you're using the code are
put onto it
an additional question you'll be asked
is how can you get a
text of a web element using selenium
well the get command is due to achieve
text of a specific web element and it's
important to remember however that the
command does not return
any parameters but just returns a string
value
so you want to be able to capture that
stream value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked
around selenium is can you handle
keyboard and mouse actions using
selenium and the answer is yes you can
but you have to make sure that you're
using the advanced user interaction
api and the advanced user interaction
api
is something that can be scripted into
your tests and it allows you
for capturing methods such as a click
and hold and drag and drop
mass events and then keyboard down or
keyboard
up a key release events so that if you
want to to capture say
the use of control shift or a specific
function button off the keyboard you'd
be able to capture those
of the following four elements which of
these elements is not a web element
method a get text b size
c get tag name d send keys
and it's b size you're going to be asked
to explain what is the difference for
when we use
find element or find elements
and so if we look at find element find
element finds the first element in the
current web page that
matches the specified located value in
contrast
find elements finds all of the elements
on the web page
that matches the specified value when
using webdriver
what are the driver close and driver
quit commands
and these are two different methods used
to close a web browser session
in selenium so driver close will close
the current web browser which your focus
is set
and driver quick closes all the browser
windows and ends the webdriver session
completely the final question that you
are likely to be asked
in using selenium is how can you submit
a form
using selenium well in this instance
that's relatively easy
the following lines of code will let you
submit a form in selenium
which would be web element el equals
driver dot find element and then you put
in the id
and the element id and then l submit
open close parentheses
semicolon so let's just get into the
first section which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is why do
you have ssl
certificates used for chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security
ssl provides for a very high level of
private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential
to ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using ssl
and you're using the private public key
model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that
the chef that you'll be able to validate
that the
nodes within your network that chef is
validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters
so you will also be asked um some
questions such as the following which is
the following commands would you use to
stop or disable the http service
when the system boots and you'll
typically get four
responses and there'll be system ctl
disable httpd.service or is it system
disable http dot
service system disable httpd or the
final option which is system ctl disable
httpd.service your answer should be the
first one which is hashtag system
ctl disable http dot service
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allow it
to function effectively and one of the
tools that you're going to be asked
about
is what is test kitchen and test kitchen
is essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to
test out your cookbook before you
actually deploy it to a real node so
some of the
commands that you would use are for
instance if you want to create an
instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances
you would do kitchen converge so a
question you'll get
is around chef is how does chef apply
differ from chef
client so fundamentally the difference
between them is that chef apply
will validate the recipe that you're
working on whereas
chef client looks to apply and validate
the entire cookbook that's run in your
server environment so one is focused on
the recipe and the other is focused on
the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines
so for instance when you're working with
puppets and you're working with
one version of puppet and you want to do
what is the command
to sign a requested certificate the top
example here is for public version 2.7
whereas the lower option here is for
puppet version
3. now something to bear in mind when
you're going through your interview
process
is that the tools that are used within
a continuous integration continuous
delivery devops
model do vary and so you want to be able
to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools
so that when you're talking to your
interviewer you're able to show
the deep knowledge that you have which
open source or community tools do you
use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
foundation of puppet itself
and so the three options you have is
being able to track configurations with
jira which you should be doing anyway
but it's a great way to be able to
clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet a
version control
can be extended with get and then the
changes should be passed through
jenkins so the three tools you want to
be looking at integration with jira
yet and jenkins so what are the
resources
in puppet well fundamentally there are
four
the resources are basic units of any
configuration management tool
they are the features of the nodes they
are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node
so as we dig deeper into puppet one of
the things that you are likely to be
asked regarding puppet is
what is a class in puppets and so a
class in puppet is
really the name blocks in your manifest
that contain the various configurations
and this can include services files
and packages and we have on the screen
here an example of what a class would
look like when you write it out and you
may want to memorize
just one class don't memorize just a
whole set of classes just memorize one
the person that's interviewing you is
just really looking for someone who has
a working knowledge they're not looking
for you to have memorized
complete massive classes but having one
small class to be able to illustrate
the experience you have is extremely
valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into
ansible one of the things that you're
going to be asked around ansible is what
is
ansible role so a role is an independent
block of tasks and variable files and
templates
embedded with inside of the playbook so
example we have here on the screen
actually shows you one role within a
playbook and in this role it is to
install
tomcat on a node again as with
previous question within puppets of a
class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two
roles so you can talk knowledgeably
about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible
when should you be using the curly
brackets and so
just as a frame of reference uh there's
often two different ways
that these kind of brackets are referred
to now they're either referred to as
french brackets or curly brackets
either way and what you'll be wanting to
ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets
within and support and really the answer
comes down to two things one is that it
makes it easier to distinguish
strings and undefined variables and the
second
is for putting together conditional
statements when you are actually using
variables and the example we have here
is this prints the value of and we have
foo
and we have to then put in the variable
conditional statement of
foo is defined as something so what is
the best way to make content reusable
and
redistributable with ansible and there's
really essentially three
the first is to include a sub module or
another file in your playbook the second
is to import an improvement of an
include which ensures that a file is
added only once
and then the third is roles to manage
the tasks within the playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a
differences between ansible and puppets
so
if we look at ansible it's a very easy
agentless installation it's based on
python
you can configure it with yaml and there
are no support for windows
in contrast puppet is an agent-based
installation
it's written in ruby the configuration
files are written in dsl
and it has support on all popular
operating systems
so we dig deeper into the actual
architecture ansible it has a much more
simple architecture and it's definitely
a push only architecture
in contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to
have a complete environment managed by
the puppet architecture
so let's get on to our next section
which is containerization
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of
docker is and docker really is the most
popular containerization environment so
docker uses a client server
architecture and the docker client is a
service which runs in a command line
and and then the docker daemon which is
run as a rest api and within the command
line will accept the requests and
interacts with the operating system in
order to build the docket images and
run the docker containers and then the
docker image is a template of
instructions which is used to create
containers
the docker container is an executable
package of applications and its
dependencies together
and then finally the docker registry is
a service to host
and distribute docker images among other
users
so you'll also be asked to provide what
are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact
um you may want to even extend it as
having what are the differences between
having a dedicated machine a virtual
machine and a docker or docker-like
environment
and really the the arguments for docker
are just absolutely fantastic you know
first of all docker does contain and
occupy docket containers occupy
significantly less space than a virtual
machine or a dedicated machine
the boot up time on docker is
significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image
docker is highly efficient and very easy
to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation uh docker data volumes
can be shared and reused among
multiple containers the argument against
virtual machines is
significant and particularly if you're
going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated
hardware and haven't moved to a cloud or
cloud-like environment
your arguments for docker are going to
be very very persuasive
be very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team
and this is something that's important
when you're going through the interview
process
but also equally important particularly
if you're working with a company that's
transitioning or going through a digital
transformation where they
aren't used to working with the tools
like docker you need to be able to
effectively
share with that team what the benefits
are so how do we share docker containers
with different
nodes and in this instance what you want
to be able to do is leverage the power
of docker swarm so docker swarm is a
tool which allows the it administrators
and developers to create and manage
clusters of swarm nodes within the
darker platform
and there are two elements to the node
there's the manager node and then
there's the
the worker node the manager node as
you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of
the agent as it gets executed so what
are the commands to create a docker
swarm
and so here we have an example of what a
manager
node would look like and once you've
created a swarm on your magic node you
can now add worker nodes to that swarm
and again when you're stepping through
this process be very precise
in the execution part that needs to be
taken
to be able to effectively create a swarm
so start with the manager node and then
you create
a worker node and then finally when a
node is initialized as a manager node it
can immediately create
a token and that token is used for the
worker nodes and associating
the ip address with the worker nodes
question 17
how to run multiple containers using a
single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually
run each of the services in isolation so
that they can
interact with each other the language
used to write out
the compose files that allow you to run
the service is called
yaml and yamus stands for yet another
markup language
so what is the use of a docker file
so a dockerfile actually is used for
creating docker images
using the build command so let's go
through and show
on the screen what that would look like
and this would be an opportunity where
if you're actually in a technical
interview you could potentially even ask
hey
can i draw on a whiteboard and show you
what the architecture for using the
build command would look like and what
the process would look like um again
when you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like
is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different
and in this instance this is a great
example of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually
show what can actually be done through
actually creating images on the
whiteboard very quickly little square
boxes where you can actually show the
flow for creating a build environment
as an architect this should be something
that you're comfortable
doing and by doing it in the interview
and certainly you want to ask permission
before you actually do it
but doing this in the interview really
helps demonstrate your
comfortable feelings of working with
these kind of architecture drawings so
back to the question of creating a
docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image
which then in turns creates the docker
container and then we are able to push
that out
up to a docker hub and then share that
docker hub
with everybody else as part of the
docker registry with the whole
network so what are the differences
between docker image and docker
containers so let's go through the
docker image
so the docker images are templates of a
docker container
an image is built using a docker file
and it stores that docker file in a
docker
repository or a docker hub and and you
can use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read-only file
system
the docker container is a collection of
the runtime instances of a docker image
and
the containers are created using docker
images and they are stored in the docker
daemon
and every container is a layer is a read
write file system so you can't replace
the information you can only append to
it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that
is the default but you can also use json
so if you
are comfortable working with json and my
that is something that you should be uh
get comfortable with
is you want to be able to use that to
name your files and as a frame reference
json is a logical way of being able to
do
value paired matching using a javascript
like syntax so you're going to be asked
to
how to create a docker container so
let's go through what that would look
and we'll break it down task by task so
the task is going to be
create a mysql docker container so to do
that you want to be able to build
a docker image or pull from an existing
docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has
my sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the
layer of read write file system is also
created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that
so what is the difference between a
registry and a repository so let's go
through that
so for the docker registry and
repository
for the registry we have docker registry
is an open source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing docker
images
whereas in contrast for repositories a
collection of multiple versions of a
docker image
in a registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names and then finally on the registry
docker also has its own default retreat
called docker hub
for the repository it is a collection of
multiple versions of docker images it is
stored in a docker registry and it has
two types a public and private registry
so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that
support docker really you know list them
all and we have listed here amazon web
services microsoft azure google cloud
rackspace but you could add in their ibm
bluemix could put in red hat really any
of
the cloud service providers out there
today do
support docker it's just become an
industry standard
so what is the purpose of expose and
publish commands
in docker so if we go through expose
is an instruction used in dockerfile
whereas publish
is used in docker run command for expose
it is used to expose
ports within a docker network whereas
with publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment
for expose it is a documenting
instruction used at the time of building
an image
and running a container whereas with
published is used as to map
a host port to a running container port
for expose is
the command used in docker whereas for
publish we use the command dash
p for when we're doing our command line
used in
docker and examples of these are expose
8080 or with docker we would put in or
for publish we'd do the example
docker run d dash p and then
0.0.0.80 a colon80
as our command line so let's look at
continuous
monitoring so with continuous monitoring
how does nagios help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications
and servers and so this is really just a
high-level question of using nagios
within your environment
and you should be able to just come back
very quickly and say nagios allows you
to help
manage the servers and check if they're
being sufficiently utilized and if there
are any task failures that need to be
addressed
and so there are three areas of
utilization and
risk that you want to be able to manage
this is being able to verify the status
and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole
and if applications are working properly
together with our web services and apis
that are reachable so the second
question you'll be asked is how does
negatives help in continuous monitoring
of systems applications and services
so it's able to do this by having the
initial negatives process and scheduler
and the additional plugins that you
would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negatives web interface to be able
to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule
so what do you mean by nagios remote
plugin executor or the
mpre of netgears so mpre allows you to
execute
plugins on links unix machines that
allow you to do
additional monitoring and machine
metrics such as
disk usage cpu load etc what are the
ports
used by nagios for monitoring purposes
in this example there are
three and they're easy to remember so i
would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six six
five six six seven and five six six
eight so there are two types of checks
within nine years so you will be asked
for
what is an active and passive check in
nagios
so an active check and is initiated by
the nagios process and is run on a
regular schedule
a passive check is initiated and formed
by an external application or process so
this may be where a system is failing
and checks are results are submitted to
nigeria's
for processing and to continue with this
for
what is an active and passive check
active checks are initiated by the check
logic within the nagios daemon negus
will
execute a plug-in and pass information
about what needs to be checked
plug-in will then check the operational
state of the host oil service
and then process the results of the host
or service check
and send out notifications in contrast
with the passive check it is an external
application that initiates the
check it writes the results of the check
to an external command line
file and i guess reads the external
command file
and places the results of all passive
checks in a queue for later processing
so you can go back
and revalidate and then negotiate may
send out notifications log alerts etc
depending on the results that they get
from checking
the information so you're going to be
asked to explain the main configuration
file and its location
in nagio so the main configuration file
consists
of a number of directives that affect
how nagios operates so consider this as
the configuration file that's
read by both nagios processor and the
cgi's
so this will allow you to be able to
manage the main configuration file
that's placed into your settings
directory
so what is the nagios network analyzer
and again hold out your four fingers
because there are four
options here so the nagios network
analyzer
one provides an in-depth look at all
your network traffic source and security
threats two allows system admins to
gather high-level information on the
health of your network
three provides a central view of your
network traffic and bandwidth data and
then
four allows you to proactive in
resolving outages abnormal behavior and
threats before they affect critical
business processes so what are the
benefits of http
and ssl certificate monitoring with
nagios
so with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have
increased server and services and
application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring
the ssl certificate monitoring allows
you for increased website availability
frequent application availability and
provides increased
security so explain virtualization with
nagios
so in responses the first thing you
should be able to talk about
is how nagios itself can run on many
different virtualization platforms
including
microsoft visual pc vmware zen amazon
ec2 etc etc
so just make sure you get that right off
the bat now yes
it was able to provide capabilities
tomorrow and so much of metrics on
different platforms
it allows for ensure for quick detection
of service and application failures
and has the ability to be able to
monitor against
many metrics including cpu usage memory
networking
and vm status so name the three
variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and
it is name use and register so name
is a template name that can be
referenced in other object definitions
use specifies the name of the template
object that you want to inherit its
properties and variables from
and register indicates whether or not
the object definition
should be registered to dagios and on
the right hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like
again you may want to be able to
memorize this as it's something that
you can actually write down and show
someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is nagios
said to be
object oriented and fundamentally comes
down to the object configuration format
that you can use in your object
definitions
it allows you to inherit properties from
other object definitions and this is
typical object oriented development and
is now applied for the nagios
environment so some of the objects that
you can
inherit are services hosts commands and
time periods
so finally explain what is state talking
in nagios
and so there are really four options
here when you're talking about state
stalking
so state stalking is used for logging
purposes in nagios
it allows you to enable for a particular
host or service that nagios will watch
over very carefully it will log any
changes it sees in the output
of the check results and then finally
helps the analysis
of log files
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here